unrest is growing in China over the
country's strict covid-19 measures fresh
protests have broken out in major cities
with hundreds rallying at beijing's
Elite Singh Hua University chanting we
want freedom many also holding up blank
sheets of paper in a symbolic protest
against State censorship more
demonstrations have also been reported
in Shanghai following clashes with
police overnight public anger has flared
after a deadly apartment block fire with
many blaming an ongoing lockdown for
hampering rescue efforts Chinese
officials have defended their serocobed
policy despite the growing public
backlash
they've become a symbol of the biggest
threat yet to China's leadership blank
pieces of paper held Aloft by protesters
like here in Beijing a silent rejection
of censorship
this rally just one of dozens that have
spread across China
's earlier huge crowds turned out in
Shanghai in a rear Defiance of Chinese
authorities
years of pandemic lockdowns have pushed
people here to their limit
hundreds face down police and called on
President Xi Jinping to step down
[Applause]
many in the crowd refusing to hide their
identities despite potentially severe
consequences for their disobedience
scuffles eventually broke out with
officers warning the crowds to move back
as police reinforcements arrived a woman
can be heard yelling you were employees
you have food to eat and money to make
what about us it's been three years
Saturday's protest came to a head
following a candlelit vigil for the
victims of an apartment fire that's
shaken the country
at least 10 died in The Blaze which
broke out on Thursday in the
Northwestern city of urumchi many have
blamed the deaths on lockdown
restrictions which they say hampered
rescue efforts with some locals banned
from leaving their homes for over three
months
udem Chi residents are now also rising
up here they chant lift the covert
lockdown
[Music]
the tension with officials boils over as
protesters break through a fence
the protests come just weeks after Xi
Jinping was reappointed as the country's
leader for an unprecedented third term
his covert restrictions are some of the
harshest globally with officials
sticking to a zero covert policy while
much of the rest of the world tries to
coexist with the virus but despite the
public backlash G shows no signs of
backing down
we can talk now to correspondent Fabian
kretchma who is in Beijing Fabian first
of all what more can you tell us about
the situation there
yeah we're basically seeing the biggest
protests in China since at least the
1990s it's really remarkable in the
night from Saturdays to Sunday several
hundreds of young people in Shanghai
gathered they did not only voice their
criticism against the zero covert policy
but also against XI jinping's rule they
were shouting down with xinji ping down
with the party I mean that's really
unheard of and you have
protests in basically all of the country
I give you one noticeable example here
in Beijing at the really very
prestigious qinghua University also
several hundreds maybe even more than 1
000 students are gathering also shouting
slogans demanding freedom and it's
really I mean they are very courageous
they are basically for the first time
speaking up and that comes really at a
great risk and I mean the Chinese
government is known to have a very low
tolerance for for criticism what does it
tell us that so many are willing now to
defy the regime to be courageous as you
just it
yeah many have had enough they feel also
like they have nothing to lose I would
say they are different motifs um
especially let's say migrant workers for
them the lockdowns are an existential
economic threat so really they have
nothing to lose for the students for
example at qinghua University for more
for them I'm sure it's a moral
obligation they want to show solidarity
because on Thursday night there was a
fire in uromuchi in in xinjiang 10
people died and many people in China
believe those deaths could have been
prevented they were basically a side
effect of those very excessive lockdowns
and it's not the first time that people
had to die because of those lockdowns
and basically every day on social media
you see um people like desperate you
know um suiciding jumping from their
roofs because they've been you know for
weeks sometimes months locked down in
their homes so um they had the feeling
now it's too much we have to show our
solidarity we have to say something and
do you think that easing China's tough
code with restrictions would be enough
to satisfy protest or is there really
maybe something deeper going on
for some yes I mean in Shanghai we've
really seen that they want more than
just the change of the covet pandemic
policy I mean they basically asked uh Xi
Jinping to step down I mean for them you
know the endless repressions the
civilians that you know came during the
pandemic but was also observable before
I think they want a different Society
I'm sure about that but also for many
other people it's really mostly the
endless covert lockdowns that you know
um uh brings their patients to an end uh
here in Beijing for example I followed
one you know residential compound they
you know fought their way to outside of
those barriers that they had in front of
their lockdown compound and they see the
problem more with um local neighborhood
comedies who abuse their power they
wanted to call the police wanted to call
the authorities because they actually
had trust in them that they would you
know correct those things so there's
really a mixed bags of of motifs behind
those protesters but all of them
definitely had enough of a zero covet
right I mean Fabian that is sort of
obviously you know makes you wonder why
is Xi Jinping insisting on these very
rigid covet measures given the low
numbers there let alone the economic and
what we see now also the social backlash
yeah that's really a complicated
question because I mean nobody knows 100
for sure um but I would say that you
know the government has put itself in a
dead end we have for more than two years
an endless propaganda telling that
there's no alternative to zero covert
that China is the only place that
managed to you know contain the virus
and now we see that this strategy is not
sustainable anymore and
um they don't know how to change it in
the last months actually for more than a
year there's so much resources and
endless testing and quarantine
facilities and they fail to start a
nationwide vaccine campaign I mean now
the people over 80 years old
um there's a rate of less than 40
percent who had a booster shot so if now
we would open up completely I'm sure
there would be a lot of damage to the
people in terms of health so now it's
really there's not good options Left
Right correspondent Fabian they're
reporting for us from Beijing thank you
so much Fabian